lucha por su país desde 2014 elena vilo
cerca es uno de los rostros femeninos
del ejército ucraniano
ahora es teniente y se prepara para
enfrentarse a las tropas rusas en kiev
[Aplausos]
por razones de seguridad
ellen habló con france24 por teléfono
creo que dentro de unos días estaré
luchando en el frente eso es lo que es
pero de todos modos porque es mi país es
mi tierra quiero defenderla tengo que
defenderlo
tengo suficiente experiencia en la lucha
creo que todos los ciudadanos ucranianos
que puedan tener un arma deberían [__]
una e ir a luchar
gracias a olena las mujeres ucranianas
pueden ahora luchar en el ejército
cuando se incorporó a la guerra que se
desarrollaba en el este de ucrania en
2014 las mujeres no podían ocupar
puestos de combate así que sirvió en un
batallón de voluntarios
como activista por la igualdad de género
elena fue una de las seis luchadoras que
aparecieron en el documental el batallón
invisible
de la ley cambió en 2016 y elena se
incorporó oficialmente al ejército
ucraniano a los 42 años ha visto un
cambio de actitud desde 2014 cuando en
ese entonces los soldados varones se
sorprendían al verla en el frente
siempre me preguntaban eres médico o
francotirador
y ahora el ejército se ha acostumbrado a
dar cabida a las mujeres artillero o
ingeniero incluso conozco a dos o tres
mujeres que comandan tanques
el ejército ha cambiado y la sociedad ha
cambiado creo que el ejército ucraniano
y la sociedad ucraniana se han
fortalecido con mujeres fuertes
para olena luchar es un derecho de la
mujer no una obligación
como ella cada vez más mujeres se
alistan en el ejército desde la reciente
invasión rusa ya sean diputadas o ex
miss ucrania